make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so before we get into this I get a
lot of questions from you guys like
recommended reading people are like I'm
gonna start with this character where do
where do I begin like one of the big
questions is spider-man right people say
I want to get started in despite a man
how do I start honestly that's just Dan
Slott spider-man big-time just look that
up the beginning of Dan slots run one of
the best spider-man runs out there but I
get all kinds of other questions who's
my favorite character and different
things like that so for those are guys
who are interested in learning about
like reading orders like were to start
with a character different things along
those lines go check out the disc court
you'll find a link down in the
description my my editor Gordon will
create a permanent link and it actually
should be in there already we don't have
a permanent link there go check out the
discourse there's sections for like
recommended reading rights like if you
want to get into stuff get semi direct
DMS on discord I do a weekly Q&A um I
haven't done it for the last couple
weeks because I was moving but I do like
a weekly Q&A different things along
those lines where I answer your
questions directly so on and so forth
and I try my best to hang out with you
guys I'm super busy but I do the best
that I can to hang out and talk to you
guys and so on and the server is always
being updated if you guys ever want to
talk to me directly discord is the best
place to do that or you can get a hold
of me on patreon I send out like weekly
emails different things like that but
yeah so getting into this this is the
star brand reborn storyline from Jason
Aaron's Avengers and this is kind of
funny the reality is there's not a lot
of meat and potatoes when it comes to
the story right there isn't a whole lot
that happens in fact Jason Aaron
actually skips around quite a bit in
this story but it does have the added
benefit of allowing us to really kind of
run over star brand right now for those
of you guys who are really familiar with
this feel free to skip forward a couple
minutes this segment is really more for
the people who are new right so if the
star brand is really a byproduct of
what's called a white event and a wide
event really comes out of Warren Ellis's
new universal right now for the white
event did take place before that in the
original iteration of new you uh really
what's called new universe but the new
universe is really more of like the
ultimate line of comics before the
ultimate line of comics right so like
what would the world look like if people
in the real world gained superpowers is
really kind of how that how that worked
um in terms of how it's being used in
the modern day that goes back to warren
ellis right and the way this played out
is that a wide event was basically an
event that took place whereby people
would be granted powers but the reason
why the wide event took place in new
Universal under warren ellis is because
you basically have it was called the old
man and this was a guy who had the mark
of the star brand the power of the star
brand and the result was that he put it
in an asteroid
when that happened he was trying to get
rid of this power when it happened
basically it created this white event
which gave us a new star grab what you
also get though and this is kind of what
Hickman did and his Avengers and New
Avengers kind of capitalizing on what
Warren Ellis did is that as it exists
right now combining both Warren Ellis's
new Universal and Jonathan Hickman as
Avengers and New Avengers is the wide
event is essentially a kind of
coming-of-age so to speak for any sort
of race that exists out there on any
particular planet when a time comes
where that race kind of reaches this
sort of point by which they can start to
evolve and and essentially move out into
like the universe more or less or they
have the potential to do so a white if
it will be initiated and what the white
event does is it supposed to create
beings of different levels of power
right so this star brand for example is
a being that has enough power to protect
the planet and its power is limitless
and then you have a night mask who's
designed to kind of help guide everybody
through what the white event is supposed
to be now the last time we saw one was
during Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and it basically went awry
right the white offend didn't happen the
way it was supposed to but the result of
that is a person who is a star brand
essentially has unlimited power right
but they're not like Franklin Richards
Franklin Richards powers are limited
only to his imagination with a star
brand it doesn't work that way
the power they possess is relative to
the threat they're facing right so if
star brand was facing off against
Galactus he'd have enough power to
basically protect the world from
Galactus if star brand is facing off
against like the Incredible Hulk then he
would have enough power to basically
face off against the Incredible Hulk and
that's in the other part of this is that
when a person becomes a star brand
they're basically met with more power
than they can usually handle right off
the bat right they're just suddenly
imbued with abilities right so imagine
tomorrow you wake up and then you've got
all this insane amount of power and you
can't really control it right that's
really what you end up running into and
that's really where that's kind of picks
up where this initially picks up with
gladiator uh who's still Magister of the
Shiar empire and again this is something
that's really been around since after
the event of war of Kings right
gladiator basically becoming the ruler
of the Shiar race and ultimately what's
happened here is one of their vessels
really like one of their prison ships
has essentially exploded out there
somewhere and multiple people were
killed the other part of this is that
those individuals who were killed or
those those individuals whose bodies
were left intact essentially received
the mark of the star brand now this is
kind of a funny thing because Jason
Aaron kind of seems to play it fast and
loose insofar as gladiator more or less
knows what's going on but nobody else
really seems to know right nobody else
really seems to be aware of exactly
what's happening
that's because of the fact that even
within the confines of Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers the New Avengers
gladiator didn't really have that much
interaction with the star brand Kevin
Connell right he didn't really have a
whole lot of interaction with him
instead he was an Avengers character
right now as you got further and further
into Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers
and as you got further and further into
the multiverse or collapse didn't
gladiator played more of a role but his
role was really confined to the earth is
the the focal point of these incursions
if we want to save our universe we have
to destroy the earth let's go blow it up
and that's where you know the Avengers
and the Shiar sort of came to blows with
one another but gladiator kind of taking
off and saying okay like we're not gonna
send any more ships into the path of
this star brand because it has more than
enough power to destroy it I'm gonna go
check it out myself
if I don't return in some measure of
time contact the Avengers right and
that's basically what ends up happening
the basically you end up having Robbie
ray is and you end up having Captain
America and Black Widow kind of a funny
thing here Captain America is talking to
Black Widow right you know and he's kind
of like well you know we're going into
space and I needed to have you know
people I needed to take people who were
on my list of individuals who can be
trusted for this and and you're on my
list that's not true black widows not on
any any major heavy hitters list because
sure she's got like a like super oh
she's got a Super Soldier Serum of sorts
but like she's no spacefaring character
in reality Captain America is not on
anybody's list at least he shouldn't be
but he's really good at rallying troops
right like if you guys have a red
Jonathan Hickman's infinity that was
like the total redemption of Captain
America in terms of why he's ever
involved in any spacefaring escapade
whatsoever do that that amazing line
when Thor kills the Builder and they're
like well what do we do now and Captain
America is like we win I was like okay
can I see your Home Slice but
nonetheless there's a couple things that
are going on here right the the
technology of black panther clearly him
as a whole the reason why you don't
really see him here is he's kind of
following up with the disappearance of
Tony Stark all we really know this going
on with Tony at least at the time this
story's being done which really kind of
seems to fly in the face of what's going
on with a lot of like the Iron Man's
story itself as well as this particular
story right because in the Iron Man
comics he's leading in in artificial
intelligence revolt against humanity
basically in this story he was
time-displaced right he ended up coming
across what looked like a calcified
prehistoric version of his helmet and
then when he touched it he was suddenly
yanked back to 1 million you know 1
million years ago so it's like okay
that's kind of weird but but things like
like black panthers technology has been
used by she-hulk for example to
basically harness gamma rays right so
instead of just sort of being out there
and being surrounded by gamma rays
not really being able to use them what
it does is it basically takes those
gamma rays and absorbs them into her
body which in turn enhances our strength
speed durability different things like
that it's really kind of a power upgrade
for she-hulk more so than anything else
the issue with this is that once they
take off take off into space about five
days later they get caught up in these
kind of magnetic webs that have been
laid by these various scavengers that
are out there and it's actually cool to
see Jason Erin do this to have him show
us this because whenever you think about
the space faring escapades in Marvel
it's very easy to get caught up in like
the Nova Corps and like quasar and like
this event and that event different
things like that but it's the small
nuances in between right the fact that
there are just roaming bands of pirates
out there who set up traps for people
and then when they catch them they
basically try to overtake their ship and
then kill everybody on board or sell
them the oldest of them into slavery and
then scrap the ship take whatever they
can and then leave release the ship into
whatever oblivion happen to be waiting
out there and then basically reset the
trap and wait for somebody else to come
along it's kind of cool to see that
that's sort of set up the issue with
this is that during this process and
we're not really told how but we can
largely kind of assume you know that it
makes sense but basically Thor has been
infected by the brood now the brood is a
group that we haven't really talked
about and they've been around for a very
very very long time and the reality is
of the brood at least according to a
history of the Marvel Universe by Mark
Waid is the universe's first predator
but the brood is one of these races
where basically it plants a kind of
embryo inside of a being but instead of
it being like the the xenomorph from the
Alien franchise right well it bursts out
from your insides what it does is it
basically re materializes you and it
turns you into a brood right so that's
kind of how they they propagate their
race is by infecting others turning them
into broods and then sending them
forward that's the whole idea behind the
brood saga when it came to the x-men
storm being turned into a brood that
kind of a thing and so as a result of
this what's been going on as for the
last five days thor has literally just
been holding his hammer and so long as
he can hold his hammer he maintains his
identity I'm Thor I'm still worthy that
kind of a thing so it's kind of cool now
of course this takes place before the
events of for by Donnie Cates
you know it doesn't they don't really
take place at the same time Marvel's
direction in terms of continuities kind
of all over the place but what you also
have is she-hulk basically just fighting
off all these different brood and all
these different you know invaders that
are out there Carol Danvers was spit out
into space to essentially find some some
means of escape and then ultimately she
does now of course in the middle of all
this Thor loses his identity right he
basically ends up turning to the brood
and sort of doing what all the brood do
which is either try to
plant their embryos on somebody else or
kill everything they find
and that's exactly what goes on here
right like literally Thor just starts
attacking Captain America now at the
same time that's going on what you've
also got is you've got Robby Reyes and
you've got Black Widow trying to outrun
Silver Surfer and the reason why is
because what Silver Surfer had done here
is in response to the power of the star
brand and recognizing the threat
represents and so far that if the star
brand chose to him was somehow able to
access the full totality of the star
brands power it would become a universal
threat basically bringing together these
various heralds all for the purpose of
tracking down the star brand and then
trying to eliminate it they've come
across the path of Robby Reyes and Black
Widow and basically come to the
realization the Avengers are trying to
intercept the star brand as well but
given the history of the star brand and
the Avengers The Herald's basically come
to the realization the Avengers will do
this time what they've done before when
when you basically at the star branded
that manifested on earth the Avengers
initially try to contain him and then
once they realize what was going on
inducted him into the ranks but because
of the fact that the the star brand as
it exists right now is literally jumping
from one world to the next just
incinerating it and then leaving well it
is very reminiscent of the Dark Phoenix
saga kind of like this star brand gone
insane it's smarter and it's more
reasonable to contain and destroy this
the star brand than it is to try to find
a way to Kauai with them or anything
along those lines so you do get some
cool moments here and there if it hadn't
been done so many times before I would
say it's cool to see Captain America
lift the hammer of Thor but we've seen
that habit of zillion times right so
like the impact is kind of gone it's
kind of disappointing and honestly and
I'll be honest with you guys after what
happened in Avengers in Avengers in game
I cannot really think of a circumstance
where anybody lifting Thor's hammer is
going to be as awesome as when Captain
America did it in that movie I mean I
know you guys reacted the same way I did
right like I know you guys watch the
videos on YouTube were like you see like
the fan the crowd reactions so like him
lifting the hammer of Thor do the
watching of the crowd reactions and the
theaters it's like amazing it gets me so
amped but no nothing's ever gonna be
that cool it's interesting and that's
basically it but none of its that
significant now one of the other cool
things that we get here is we get the
Silver Surfer facing off against Robby
Reyes now if this was like Johnny Blaze
or if it was Danny ketch I would say
okay this is a pretty predictable fight
but remember Robby ray is is in a lot of
ways the new Ghost Rider on the block
right he's the new kid he's the new guy
he's been around for a little while but
he was he was not
anywhere near as long as Danny ketch or
Johnny Blaze and so in a lot of ways
he's still basically learning how to use
his abilities now as time has passed
Marvel has expanded the role of Ravi
Reyes so his powers are more closer in
line with the traditional ghostwriter
powers right so for a long time he was
not able to use the penance stare which
is one of the powers of the Ghost Rider
to force a being to basically feel every
ounce of pain they've ever caused anyone
they've ever encountered over the course
of their lives right so like if Galactus
was made to feel the penance stare
I think the lockers was basically
experienced every ounce of pain he's
caused all the trillions of beings that
have been snuffed out by his existence
as the devourer of worlds right he would
probably render Galactus insane but one
of the cool things to come out of this
is because Ghost Rider is so powerful
right because he's powered by the cosmic
demon Mephisto because he's so powerful
basically Black Widow ends up taking off
with the Ghost Rider cart and then in
turn Robby Reyes knocks the Silver
Surfer off his surfboard and then takes
it right so basically Robby Reyes steals
the Silver Surfer surfboard which is
awesome but it lasts like that it lasts
for like a split second because remember
the surfboard of the Silver Surfer is
part and parcel to himself right and so
basically just recalls it right it's
like Thor's hammer you never really see
an instance where somebody takes Thor's
hammer and then keeps tore from using it
right I mean it's like this is my hammer
now and they just take it forever and
Thor never gets it back right I mean
Thor can just summon his hammer to
himself and so long as Thor remains
worthy and the person who's currently
holding the hammer isn't so strong that
the hammer cannot leave their grasp Thor
will always get it back right and so
it's the same thing with Silver Surfer
sport right he's just like to me my
board and then just please Robby Reyes
you know it basically just leaves them
you know and that's it you know he ends
up in the car with Black Widow and
that's the end of that right and so the
result of this is that we basically end
up kind of you know picking up with them
once they're sort of on this location
you know in this this particular area
you do have black widow who kind of
Dawn's a Iron Man suit which is actually
kind of cool but again a lot of what
we're seeing here and this may very well
be Jason Aaron just trying to kind of do
a tour to France of the kind of various
aspects of what the Avengers have done
in the past but we're not really seeing
anything new here right like Iron Man
using his technology to create suits for
other people that's been done before now
it is cool to see Black Widow right
Black Widow having an Iron Man suit in
and of herself because what this does is
it enhances what's already there right
Black Widow is exceedingly capable when
it comes to like hand-to-hand combat and
strategy if I'm Captain America and I'm
sitting around making a list of people
I'm like all right guys
we're gonna go into space to fight
Galactus who we're gonna take black
widows name is not gonna be on that list
but with regards to like this kind of a
scenario I guess it does sort of make
sense right her fighting against you
know some some forces that are out there
using her strength you know throwing
boulders at them different things along
those lines it's a cool little thing but
it's by no means a huge moment right
it's not a big significant moment it's
just kind of a thing that happens you
know that their features are character
really one of the big things that come
out of this is blade essentially bonding
itself to boy thing right now boy thing
is really kind of like this sort of
leftover this kind of remnant of Man
Thing Man Thing you know how many of you
guys know about him but he's actually
one of the more intriguing characters in
comics Man Thing is basically a guardian
of the Florida Everglades right and the
reason why is because inside the Florida
Everglades is a portal to what's
basically the Nexus of all realities
right so if you could somehow pass the
Man Thing and we'll talk about how
that's very difficult to do here in a
second but you get somehow past the man
thing you could enter into the Nexus of
realities and what you would see are
like just these twisting bridges and all
these different paths that lead and like
these different portals and barriers and
things like that essentially you could
just travel from one universe to the
next by using this this sort of
dimensional gateway more or less or this
dimensional kind of Nexus now it is kind
of cool because it's one of many
instances many variations of ways to
access different universes but the fact
remains that the reason why this is kind
of cool is because in response to what's
happening in the various harrell's that
are coming down on everybody boy thing
basically Bond's itself to blade and
this is an excruciating concept and it
goes into our discussion about how it
could be difficult to pass the man thing
in the Florida Everglades because for
those individuals who encounter Man
Thing and they feel fear they'll burn at
his touch and it's usually enough to
incinerate a person right it's usually
enough to destroy a person for blade
he's kind of a necessity here right so
he's able to kind of keep himself going
but boy thing it basically attached
herself to him now if this was Man Thing
right like the full-on man think it
probably would have killed blade but
what it does is it allows him to
basically adapt this play that he has
and then Pierce the body of the Silver
Surfer and that's why the Silver Surfer
doesn't really seem to get into a
straight-up skirmish with blade and the
reason why is because given the power of
man things like given the power of what
blade has right now he could feasibly
burn the Silver Surfer now we've never
really seen an instance where that's
happened so at that point we're just
kind of guessing right we'd never seen
someone like the Silver Surfer show up
on earth trying to enter the Nexus of
all realities encounter the man thing in
the Man Thing says you feel fear and
then burn the Silver Surfer alive we've
never really seen that
happened before but it's also one of
these things where Jason Aaron kind of
avoids it intermittently and the reason
why is because relatively close to them
there's this massive explosion where the
star brand has basically gone off again
and destroyed another world and so when
this happens suddenly you have the
arrival of gladiators and gladiators
showing up here he's trapped a star ran
down before anybody else did and
basically end up finding out is this
star brand is a pregnant woman right so
here's a question you have to ask who
actually has the marker the star brand
is it the woman or her child I would
surmise it's her child that has the
power of the star brand and it's kind of
exiting out through the woman herself
but regardless of the situation
gladiator immediately goes to take her
out now when it comes to gladiator his
loyalty is to the Shiar empire when he
was leader of the of the the Shiar
Imperial Guard which is pretty much all
forms all standards of measurement the
most elite fighting force in all of the
universe right like there are very very
few teams that come close to the power
of the Imperial Guard but when it comes
to a gladiator his role is to protect
the Shiar Empire right so during his
time as leader of the Imperial Guard you
eventually saw the ousting of lilandra
who was the Empress after her her
brother de Ken was defeated during the
original Phoenix and Dark Phoenix saga
and so when you ended up seeing Gabriel
summers the third summer's brother the
omega-level mutant who basically left
Earth and then conquered the Shiar
Empire gladiators role was to serve
Gabriel summers right he serves the
throne it doesn't matter who it is
that's on that throne now but at this
point in time when he's leader of the
Shiar his role is to safeguard the Shiar
Empire and he'll do whatever he needs to
do in order to ensure that happens even
if it means taking out a pregnant woman
it's hardcore and it's extreme but so is
gladiator right does that's that's where
this is why I say if gladiator ended up
in the MCU and it was one of these
things cuz you wouldn't he wouldn't
really openly provoke a fight like
Stannis would but it was one of those
things were like for whatever reason the
various forces of Earth ended up facing
off against the Shiar the earth
superheroes would get obliterated by
like by glide it probably a gladiator by
himself but also with the the Shiar
Imperial Guard like he'd be more than
enough but then you have the other
Avengers to basically jump in and say
we're not about this kind of business
right like we're not gonna take out a
pregnant chick so they really kind of
offer a helping hand and then the
heralds sort of watch it go down right
and so the way this plays out is at one
point in time this woman basically were
to add at a Roxxon plant in Kansas right
in rocks on basically shut down the
plant and moved it out to man report
which really falls directly in line with
Roxxon as one of the most corrupt
organizations out there which has
evolved in everything right like human
trading drug trafficking buying
politician
and things like that renting politicians
were time-to-time like it's one of these
things were like they're a super corrupt
organization but what it end up
happening here is she had basically been
brought by space coyotes right these
essentially ex shield agents who are
flying around and basically smuggling
people out of earth now we're not
explicitly given a whole lot of
exposition here right so we don't really
know if this was done because there's
just greener pastures out there in space
kind of makes sense because when you
look at earth in Marvel Comics it
basically sucks
a comparison like pretty much all the
other worlds out there that are far more
advanced technologically but regardless
of the circumstance she ended up being
transported into Shiar space and why she
was there she essentially worked on
these various plants picking berries and
so on really seems kind of me an
allegory of like Hispanics smuggled into
the u.s. more or less but the result of
this is that ultimately she's busted by
the Shiar and then ultimately put aboard
a prison ship where she's supposed to
serve three years in a Shiar prison
during this time and there's no real
indication as to why she was chosen as
the star brand now when it comes to a
person being chosen as a star brand no
rhyme or reason behind that is never
explored right it's never really
explained we literally went from new
Universal with with Warren Ellis to
where it was a result of the star brand
basically being put onto a onto an
asteroid and then ultimately coming back
to earth and bonding itself to a person
to Jonathan Hickman were like Kevin
Connell was chosen but only because the
various space stations that initiate
these wide events hit the panic button
and it was just a random person was
chosen the normal indication is that the
type of person this chosen is a person
that can do good right they can they can
actually serve the role of protecting
the world right they have the courage
the fortitude the willpower to be able
to pull that off in this instance
somebody was just arbitrarily selected
to become the star brain and when that
happened the massive release of power
ended up destroying the ship and then
she doesn't really have the ability to
control any of the power of the star
brand and so literally she's just been
jumping from world of world trying to
figure out how these powers were trying
to understand what's been going on and
in these moments of pain where she's
essentially getting ready to give birth
to a child the power just manifests with
explosive results and destroys worlds
different things like that so it's not
as though she was marked with the power
of the star brand gained these abilities
and then just went on a crusade to make
the world make the universe pay for her
suffering or anything like that she's
basically in a situation she doesn't
fully understand and doesn't know how to
control his power the other part of this
is that where she does give birth to the
baby she ends up dying in the process
and this is will re-enter finding out
that it is actually the baby who
received the mark of the star brand not
the woman herself and so as a result of
that of course the offenders end up
taking the baby and basically saying
we're gonna raise this child we're gonna
we're gonna bring this child in and it's
going to become it's gonna become a
full-fledged member of the Avengers we
will take care of it in which case the
lighnator basically says okay if you do
this then it's on you right if something
happens and this maybe becomes a threat
to the universe in my Empire I will come
back and I will do whatever I have to do
even if it means killing all of you The
Herald's say the exact same thing we'll
keep an eye on what's going on we'll
understand if that baby becomes a threat
to the universe will destroy everybody
on earth and so what you end up having
is the Avengers coming back to their
base of operations and they ask what's
probably the most important question if
this baby has the mark of the star brand
and if the mark of the star brand
manifests in whatever form of power this
child needs your this child feels like
it needs and it doesn't fully understand
itself or the world around it and
something scares it or starts crying
what's going to happen this is a very
real and dangerous situation right
because you're talking about a being
that could at any point in time have the
power to destroy anything up to and
including the universe and if that's the
case this baby could wipe out all of
existence like that not even really
intending to just in the blink of an eye
just like it would just destroy
everything and so it's like okay just
like this baby is probably the most
powerful but the most dangerous being in
all of reality and Marvel Comics right
now without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are no
here to come as explain make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace okay I want to
give a shout out to Kyle be David
Joseph's been John H AJ Matt in Jeff our
John H lean and mean which is an awesome
name Jason see Austin s Austin a Joey M
Steven Z Austin B Adam K and Genesis 9:6
team you remember guys you could send me
messages and I'll run off whatever your
message is at the end of the video so
long as there's nothing crazy but if you
want to put a message in there send me
an email Rob at Robert Jefferson comm
and if you're one of these people who
get shout outs
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch it guys
[Music]
[Music]